ten years ago I taught some eighth
graders science the principal said Oh
cliff you can teach exactly as you wish
so my idea and teaching is everyday have
the kids go home and do an experiment
and first thing I did was say okay a
people's here's a homework assignment
measure the area of the sheet of paper
use metric units and show your work and
by the way here's a ruler for you so I
don't know what's the area the sheet of
paper just go do it bring it in tomorrow
so the obvious thing to do is you take
your ruler you measure across here 20
centimeters this way you go across this
way you measure up and down 26
centimeters this way 20 centimeters
times 26 centimeters should be around
520 square centimeters okay that much
you would do I do my students didn't
realize is of course this reflects the
type of science problem or math problem
that has lots of wrinkles in
difficulties for example Oh what do you
mean what do you mean by the area of
this sheet of paper the front side or
the front plus the back or maybe just
the back side oh did you include the
circles that have been knocked out do
they count as part of the area worse
than that when you measured this did you
realize that its height over here is
different from its height over here
let's put this piece of paper onto a
square sheet of paper oh this isn't a
rectangular piece of paper
in other words multiplying height times
width doesn't work you're gonna have to
have at least some kind of outer product
or an integral perhaps the rulers that I
gave to my students 9 10 11 12 13 14 15
16 17 17 18 19 centimeters ah there's
something wrong with this awfulest
measure company
it's an imperfect dough in other words
this is a comment about doing science
what always examine the assumptions that
you're making whenever you make a
measurement whenever you write something
hey look for look for the places where
you have ambiguous statements what's the
area of this sheet of paper healthy I
just don't trust your measurement tools
good science does not mean getting the
perfect answer good science means
figuring out what could go wrong how did
your students do how many of these
inflated tricks did your students pick
up on oh so I had two classes fifteen
sixteen people in each class this is 10
12 years ago one kid right away picked
up hey there's these holes in it I'll
have to subtract the holes a few PI R
squared e figured subtracted from it
another kid said wait a second I don't
know what you mean by area in fact two
or three kids said oh there's it front
side or front plus back was just the
back side nobody picked up on the
imperfecto ruler and the shape nobody
really saw that nobody saw this coming
and no one recognized that oh they'd
been handed a bill of goods
Brady people write to me and say I'm
thinking of going to college how do I
write an essay people write to me and
say I'm trying to get into grad school
what should I say on my application my
idea is what I want to see is somebody
who's how to figure things out who says
I don't know now but I got an O and
somebody somebody who's got enthusiasts
not somebody who's boring or puts me to
sleep
that naturally doesn't come naturally
who knows I mean to me to me
I can't stand not I want to know things
I gotta know things what's the what's
the unbuffered wait wait wait wait wait
wait what's the mathematician of the
German mathematician we must know we
will know what's his epitaph what was
his named uh he'll come on you must know
Oh hold on we must know we must go look
him up real fast we'll take a second
well he's curious he's going off to fun
I hear the mathematician is Helders it
was David Hilbert on his grave it says
we must know we will know I like that
feeling 1894 1895 in Switzerland came up
with an absolutely wonderful device a
calculator called the millionaire this
device check this out this will not only
hey go over here over here